[Music]
good afternoon everybody
hi hello
good afternoon
welcome to the west falmouth library my
name is leslie little and i'm president
of the board of trustees of the library
i'm very happy to see such a wonderful
turnout today to hear nathaniel
philbrick discuss his best-selling book
in the heart of the sea
before we get to the real reason we're
all here today i'd like to tell you a
little about the library the west
falmouth library is a private library
which is funded primarily by membership
dues and contributions and it is
supported by the efforts of a group of
volunteers the board decided that
today's event would be free of charge to
the community but i encourage you to
make a donation to the library so that
we can continue to offer this type of
program in the future
after nat's discussion
eight cousins bookstore will be selling
copies of the book that you can have
signed by nat
we'll be serving some light refreshments
and i hope you'll stay for a bit and
enjoy the library and now to present
today's author i'd like to introduce
penny hare a member of the board of and
a friend of both the philbrick and
douthat families
[Applause]
well welcome to all
and to particularly to you nat
thank you for giving us this opportunity
to share with you
uh the success you are having with your
boat book heart of the sea the tragedy
of the ship whale ship essex
this is a return to west falmouth
for nat
his grandparents used to have a summer
house here
and he spent summers here
instructing
sailors both at the chap court yacht
club
and at the wild harbor yacht club
and i thought some of his students were
going to be here today but they may be
here later
while he was here he also pursued
the sunfish world championship
he also pursued and romanced
another westbound salient instructor
melissa philbrick who is now his uh
elizabeth who is now his his wife
and a quick aside when he was going to
get married
and they were both being married down at
the church of the messiah we had
a little concern about what type of
shoes
they would wear would they be topsiders
or would they be dress-ups
and they had dress-ups
[Music]
nat
raced in the world
sunfish championships in both holland
and puerto rico finishing the fifth and
third with over a hundred participants
in each event and there's a
versie of the flag
in holland
therefore because of his interest in
sailing some of his first articles
appeared in
cruising world and then there was a
spoof on yachting magazine called
yatcheting
his last book
on sailing is called the second wind
supposedly a midlife crisis he wanted to
try
another
go at a world championship
i don't think 37 is a midlife crisis but
apparently he did
since he's been in nantucket he has read
written several books about nantucket
and of course the latest being the heart
of the sea which is now the number two
bestseller
on the new york
book list so nat thank you for coming
and we look forward to you
thanks
well thank you penny it's really great
to be here it was we were melissa and i
were reminiscing as we drove down it was
exact almost exactly 26 years ago when
we met uh applying bottom paint to a
float at the chapacoite yacht club
and things haven't changed that much
except of course for all of us here but
it is simply great to be here and penny
thanks so much for spearheading bringing
me here and uh
it's been an interesting month and a
half of traveling all over the country
and spreading the gospel of nantucket
and the whale ship essex but this really
does feel like a homecoming so uh thanks
again for making this possible
well november
actually in august of 1819 just a few
days as it so happened after the birth
of hermann melville
the whale ship essex left nantucket for
the last time she was a fairly typical
whale ship of her era she was about 100
feet long
238 tons and had a 21-man crew half of
them were from nantucket the other half
were off islanders from some of them
from cape cod with seven or seven of
them being african-americans who had
been delivered on a packet ship from
boston
the essex just a few days out just as
she entered the gulf stream was hit by a
squall and knocked over on her bee men's
two of the whale boats were lost these
whale boats were only 25 feet long these
were the boats with which the men would
pursue the whales and they lost two of
the three that they needed to uh hunt
the whales
captain pollard a young captain only 28
years old and a first-time captain who
was struggling to establish his own
style of command decided to head back
for to do repairs but his a very hard
driving first mate 22 year old owen
chase convinced him to go on to to find
spare whale boats in perhaps the the
azores and cape verde islands where it
was common for whale ships to provision
at that time today nantucketers go to
hyannis and north dartmouth to provision
in those days they went to the azores
and cape verde islands where things like
hogs and vegetables and fruit could be
bought at a fraction of the cost
well pollard said let's go back his
first mate said let's keep going and in
a rare
uh moment captain pollard said okay
you've convinced me to go on now
captains are not necessarily known for a
democratic style of leadership but
pollard once again was new to it and
beginning to feel his way along and of
course the condition of the men's whale
boats would have a great deal to do with
what would happen to them in the months
ahead
luckily they would find one extra boat
in the cape verde islands they would
round the horn and then head up the west
coast of south america which had been a
whaling ground for the nantucketers for
several decades after a stop off at the
galapagos islands where they rounded up
hundreds of galapagos tortoises which
averaged about 80 pounds each
they would stack them in the bolt in the
hold of the ship
and then also leave them to wander the
decks of the whale ship so if you can
imagine one of these whale ships look
something like a a barnyard with goats
and pigs and galapagos tortoises
wandering the deck
then with with these tortoises aboard
they headed west out to a newly
discovered whale ground called
appropriately enough the offshore ground
the the essex was 1500 miles to the west
of the galapagos almost smack dab on the
equator with the youngest boy aboard
thomas nickerson a name familiar to many
of you cape codders at the helm he was
only 15 years old
when a huge whale a sperm whale 85 feet
long almost the length of the ship
appeared on the port side
initially the men were not concerned
never before in the history of the whale
fishery had a sperm whale
attacked a whale ship and so they just
sort of watched it but this whale began
to move and it began to pick up speed
until it slammed into the left side the
port side of the ship knocking all the
men off their feet sending those
galapagos tortoises skittering like
hockey pucks along the deck
the men were absolutely stunned they it
was something out of hitchcock's the
birds in which a normally benign beast
had be had turned them into the prey the
whale went underneath the ship surfaced
beside beside the ship hold a hull
and with the the tail pointed towards
the rudder
first mate owen chase picked up the
killing lance with which whalers
normally killed whales the whale was so
close he motioned to attempt to stab
this whale that had dared to attack a
ship but he waited in an
uncharacteristic moment of caution when
he noticed that the tail was within just
a few feet of the rudder of the ship
and the real and since the essex was as
far out as any nantucket whale ship had
ever been he didn't dare risk that
fragile steering mechanism so the whales
of course sprang to life
swam to lord of the ship and went
through almost a spasmodic kind of
behavior snapping its jaws in what the
whalemen interpreted as a sign of rage
swam ahead of the ship a couple hundred
yards turned around and came at it twice
the original speed stoving in the the
port bow as if it was an eggshell
according to one account this 80 ton
whale about the third of the weight of
the ship even drove the ship backwards
but soon the ship was no longer going
backwards it was now going down the
whale disengaged its head from uh the
ship
swam off never to be heard from again
now leo dicaprio on the titanic had
nothing on what these men experienced on
the essex it was going down very quickly
bow first
and there was a spare whale boat tied to
a rack
on the aft portion of the ship normally
it took about 10 minutes involving the
entire crew to un-rig one of these boats
get it ready and put it to to see but
these men had only a fraction of that
time
chase with the crew that were on the
ship there were two whale boats at this
time hunting whales so this was just a
small portion of the crew began to rig
this whale boat while i was the
african-american steward who really
would save the day because he realized
that if they didn't have their
navigational equipment their compass
their quadrant their navigational guide
that they would be lost in the middle of
the this limitless pacific ocean
so he went down below to the captain's
cabin even though it was rapidly filling
with water came up uh with this
equipment even went down a second time
had to swim his way out and by the time
he came up the ship was listening to
starboard the men jumped into the whale
boat rode off and they were only two and
a half lengths away when the the whale
ship capsized behind them they stood
there stunned looking at the the wreck
that had once been their home
by this point the other two whale boats
which had captain pollard and second
mate matthew joy realized the ship had
vanished behind the horizon they had
absolutely no idea what had happened
disengaged the whales that they were
attached to and rode back as quickly as
they could
what they saw
uh was unbelievable to them their ship
looking like a rock uh nickerson would
later say
in the middle of the sea
pollard wrote up to first mate owen
chase and asked my god mr chase what has
happened his simple reply was we have
been stove by a whale
so here they were in the middle of the
pacific
with a big question before them what to
do next well the first thing they did
was scavenge as much provisions from
this wreck as they could they got some
hard tack some dried bread about the
consistency of a brick some water which
they stored in casks and two of those
galapagos tortoises per boat
they rigged them up as small schooners
two small sails and a jib
and then they had a decision to make
where to go
captain pollard made the proposal that
makes sense to us today he said let's
sail with the trade winds to the islands
to the west he suggested tahiti one of
the society islands would take them a
matter of weeks but if all went well
they would be safe they had about what
they figured 60 days of provisions but
once again his mates owen chase
leading them
proposed another
another suggestion
what they were fearful of were cannibals
these men had no firm knowledge of what
was going on with these islands this is
a new era
new era in pacific whaling they had just
made it this far west and what they had
heard about were rumors of cannibalism
and having the the sperm whale turned
the tables on them the the first the
first mate was in no mood to uh trust in
the unknown and so he proposed this he
described it as sailing up the coast
they they would have to sail directly
against the wind if they wanted to head
immediately toward south america and
they couldn't do that in their whale
boats which at this time were not
equipped with center boards he proposed
that they sailed south almost 1500 miles
with luck they could do it in 30 days
where they be reached a band of what
they called variable breezes they would
ride those variable breezes take a left
ride those breezes to south america in
another 30 days and if all went well
they'd be safe in a civilized port in
two months
pollard once again succumbed to his two
mates and said okay i guess you're right
let's do it as thomas nickerson that
young boy would later write late in life
this was the fatal error because instead
of everything going right everything
would go wrong you'll have to read the
book to get the details
but
they would
suffer relentless calms
terrible storms
within a week of leaving the essex
captain pollard's boat at night would be
attacked by another whale a killer whale
that would play with the whale boat as
if a cat would with a mouse stoving in
the bow forcing them to repair the boat
in the open ocean
within a month met some of the men were
about to die of dehydration
it was really water they needed the most
they were living on a cup a day
when they stumbled across an island
henderson island they initially they
thought oh they could see green
vegetation this must have plenty of
water but unfortunately
this was a barren coral atoll and it
took them a day and a half of frantic
searching before they found
a a spring bubbling up beneath the
tideline was only available to them for
a week a hour at a time but they were
able to fill their casks but after
another week on the island they realized
that there was not enough wildlife to
support twenty men
they realized they had to head head
towards south america still three
thousand miles away
before they left three of the men two of
them cape codders one an englishman said
thank you very much we're going to stay
on dry land it was it would turn out to
be a very wise decision because only
nantucketers would emerge from those
whale boats alive
within weeks of leaving henderson island
people would begin to die of starvation
the whale boats would become split up
one whale boat of that of matthew joy's
would never be heard from again
owen owen chases the first mate's boat
would be the first to be rescued almost
within sight of massafura island
uh
two and a half months after the sinking
of the essex there would only be three
men alive all of them nantucketers
but it would really be on captain
pollard's boat that the central drama of
the essex would occur
they would be down to four men by this
time
all of them nantucketers on captain
pollard's boat by this time they had
resort had to resort to survival
cannibalism where when some a man would
die they would reluctantly eat the the
flesh of the body but these four men had
nothing left to eat and they realized if
something wasn't done
all of them might die so one of the
teenagers was with captain pollard
proposed that they attempt the custom of
the sea in which they would draw lots to
see who should be sacrificed so the rest
might live pollard initially said no i
can't i can't submit to this but once
again he would be talked out of his
initial decision by the three teenage
nantucketers all of whom had grown up
together one of them included pollard's
much younger cousin owen coffin
pollard said okay we'll do it they they
took some pieces of paper put them in a
hat
drew the lots and it would be pollard's
teenage cousin owen coffin who would
draw the short piece of paper
initially pollard said boy if you don't
want to go through this i will kill the
man who attempts to touch you he and by
this time their sufferings were so
severe that death was as much a release
as anything
and
he said owen said i like my lot as well
as any other they had to draw lots one
more time to see who would execute the
boy it would be charles ramsdell his his
teenage boyhood friend who once again
refused to go through with it but by
this time the mechanisms of this
terrible ordeal were in place and he was
uh shot with a pistol that was on the
whale boat and quickly dispatched
weeks later
three months after the sinking of the
essex
captain pollard's boat would be cited by
a nantucket whale ship almost within
sight of the chilean coast it was the
whale ship doe fan
they saw this whale boat bobbing uh
seems seemingly without direction uh in
the middle of the ocean they sailed up
to it and looked down and there were two
men pollard and ramsdell and they were
found and i'm quoting here sucking the
bones of their dead messmates which they
were loathed to part with
they were delirious they were living on
the marrow in the bones
and
were reluctant to give those bones up
even though they had known they were
saved
amazingly pollard would make a trip a
very quick recovery
that night he would tell the captain in
startling detail everything that had
happened this would become the basis of
what was known as the paddock letter
copies of this letter would circulate
through the whale fleet in fact one of
these letters copies would make its way
back to nantucket before the survivors
returned
and so that the nantucketers learned of
their disaster
even before they heard it from the lips
of the survivors the survivor the five
nantucketers would would be brought to
valparaiso chile a rescue ship would be
sent out to those three men all of whom
were still alive although that spring
that had miraculously appeared below the
tideline never again appeared above it
because apparently it was a
full moon high tide in the week they
were on that island so these men were
suffering as much from dehydration as
they were starvation the captain of the
rescue ship said they had it at no more
than a month to live when he picked them
up
the essex men would return pollard would
be the last to return he would have a
relapse after his confession
and he would return in august of 1821
1500 nantucketers were assembled on the
wharf
almost a quarter of the town's
population and according to an
eyewitness it was an awestruck silent
crowd when the captain stepped off the
the ship onto the wharf and made his way
home
he had made a promise to his cousin that
he would
speak to his mother and tell her
everything that had happened so pollard
went to his aunt
told her that her son had expressed his
love to her and the circumstances under
which he had died and quite
understandably she could no longer stand
the sight of him after that but the rest
of nantucket uh
was more lenient when it came to these
men they this was a maritime community
they understood that
cannibalism in survival situations was
relatively common at sea at this time
the confidence in pollard was such that
he went out within months of his return
to nantucket the captain of another
whale ship the two brothers and i think
it's an indication of the character the
high esteem his men had for him in that
accompanying him were not only thomas
nickerson that young boy who was at the
helm of the ship when it was attacked
but also charles ramsdell the boy who
had been picked up in the whale boat
with him at the end
pollard however would prove to be an
unlucky man
uh
he would take his new whale ship the two
brothers around the horn they'd be
heading out to yet again another newly
discovered whale ground the japan ground
they were sailing in a storm to the
southwest of the hawaiian islands when
in the night they came up on french
frigate shoals the ship was pounded to
pieces on a coral reef can you imagine
their emotions when they took to the
whale boats in the middle of the night
luckily they were rescued that day
but pollard realized that his career had
was ended
he returned to nantucket and would would
live out his life
as a night watchman
now
first mate owen chase in that first
summer of his return to nantucket would
pen
a narrative of the essex disaster and
quickie journalism is nothing new
chase's account was out with almost
exactly a year after the sinking and it
would get wide distribution
and uh two
two decades later
a young whaleman by the name of hermann
melville was in a whale ship almost at
the same latitude as the sinking of the
essex he had heard about the essex from
his fellow crew members when they came
across another
whale ship and on board was the son of
owen chase melville made a point of
speaking with the boy
the boy uh told him everything he knew
and then went to a sea chest and took
out his own copy of his father's
narrative and gave it to melville that
night melville would read it and of
course uh within a decade later would
write moby dick
in which uh the pequod is rammed by a
whale in that that amazing climax and so
it's it's really with
melville's use of owen chase's narrative
that i think
most people have known about the essex
um through the centuries
however there was someone else who would
write a story a narrative of his
experience on the essex thomas nickerson
that young boy
late in life would retire to the island
by that point nantucket nantucketers
were no longer fishing for whales they
were fishing for tourists
and he had a guest house on north water
street the building still stands
and one of his guests was a professional
writer by the name of leon lewis who
encouraged him to write his own
narrative of the essex
nickerson would do so but unfortunately
this was in the age before xerox
machines and he sent him his only a copy
of the narrative
the writer would never do anything with
this account and it would
be assumed lost not until 1980 would
this narrative make its way back to
nantucket where the whaling expert
eduard stackpole
recognized it to be the long-lost
narrative of the essex
and and nickerson's narrative which was
published on nantucket by the historical
association on the island in 1984 was a
huge help to me because where owen chase
devotes just pages to what happened on
the essex prior to the attack nickerson
devotes chapters and he tells us all
sorts of details that owen chase an
officer who wanted to put some very bad
decisions in the best possible light
did not choose to tell his readers and
so with the help of nickerson
in writing my account i was able to to
talk about how the some of these
decisions were made
who these men were uh
they emerged as people with the help of
nickerson rather than faceless uh
sufferers suffering the worst things
that fate can throw at anyone
and so uh
one of the other things i tried to do
with this narrative was to uh establish
the historical context of of the essex
the essex uh was
was tied of course with nantucket an
extraordinary microcosm in 1819. this is
an island that was a mobile oil of its
day
it was a global oil center
this was before petroleum the discovery
of petroleum and it was nantucket whale
oil that lit the streets
of london that lubricated the machines
of the industrial age and uh
so that the the story of the essex was
something that was tied to a community
that had a real worldwide notoriety uh
people look to nantucket as an emblem of
how a new nation such as america could
conduct itself as a world power and so
with this story i i not only wanted to
tell us an amazing survival tale but but
reveal um
a moment in an american history and in a
way rescue the story from melville
because it's um
it's not something more than raw
material for melville's miraculous art
this is a story of america that i think
many people
under appreciate how the sea was a
important part of america's history
and what i'd like to do now
is read to you a few uh selections
that uh sort of give you an idea of what
i was trying to do with with this story
and one of the uh the paradoxes that
really define the island of nantucket
and the nantucket whaleman is the fact
that many of these men were quakers
quakers are of course pacifists when it
comes to the human race
uh and yet these men were probably some
of the bloodiest and most effective
killers the world has ever known
and i think this combination of of
spirituality and violence is one that
really uh still applies to who we are
today um as a nation we are a nation
that is very proud of our religious
beliefs our spirituality we're a very
pious people and yet we also like our
guns we are very violent people we kill
each other at appalling rate and i think
this combination of spiritual
spirituality and violence is something
that nantucketers embodied and which
lives on today in america and so what i
i'll read to you
right now is about this whole paradox
these were quakers but these were as
melville said quakers with a vengeance
passion stirred beneath nantucket's
quaker facade
life might seem restrained and orderly
as hundreds sometimes thousands of
people made their way to meeting each
thursday and sunday the men in their
long dark coats and wide brimmed hats
the women in long dresses and
meticulously crafted bonnets
but factors besides quakerism and a
common heritage also drove the nantucket
psyche in particular an obsession with
the whale
no matter how much the inhabitants might
try to hide it there's a savagery about
this island a bloodlust and pride that
bound every mother father and child in a
clannish commitment to the hunt
the imprinting of a young nantucketer
began at the earliest age the first
words a baby was taught included the
language of the chase town or for
instance a wampanoag word meaning that
the whale has been cited for a second
time
bedtime stories told of killing whales
and eluding cannibals in the pacific
one mother approvingly recounted how her
nine-year-old son attached a fork to the
end of a ball of darning count cotton
and then proceeded to harpoon the family
cat
the mother happened into the room just
as the terrified pet attempted to escape
and unsure of what she had found herself
in the middle of she picked up the
cotton ball like a veteran harpooner the
boy shouted pay out mother pay out there
she sounds through the window
there was rumored to be a secret society
of young women on the island whose
members pledged to marry only men who
had already killed a whale to help those
young women identify them as hunters
boat steers which is another word for
harpooner wore chalk pins small oak pins
used to keep the harpoon line in the bow
groove of a whale boat on their lapels
boat steers superb athletes with
prospects of lucrative captaincies were
considered the most eligible of
nantucket bachelors
if they had game shows back then it
would have been um
a nantucket boatsteer instead of a
millionaire
instead of toasting a person's health a
nantucketer offered invocations of a
darker sort
death to the living long life to the
killers success to sailors wives and
greasy luck to whalers
despite the bravado of this little ditty
death was a fact of life with which all
nantucketers were thoroughly familiar
in 1810 there were 47 fatherless
children on nantucket while almost a
quarter of the women over the age of 23
the average age of marriage had been
widowed by the sea
in old age nickerson this is thomas
nickerson still visited the graves of
his parents in the old north burial
ground which still exists
in 1819 during the last few weeks before
his departure aboard the essex he
undoubtedly made his way to this
fenced-in patch of sun-scorched grass
and walked among its canted stones
nickerson's father had been the first of
the parents to die on november 9 1806 at
the age of 33. his gravestone read
crushed as the moth beneath thy hand we
mulder to the dust our feeble powers can
near withstand and all our beauties lost
nickerson's mother who had borne five
children died less than a month later at
the age of 28. her oldest living
daughter was eight years old her only
son was not yet two her inscription read
this mortal life decays a pace how soon
the bubbles broke
adam and all his numerous race are
vanity and smoke
nickerson who was raised by his
grandparents wasn't the only orphan
aboard the essex his friend barzilla ray
had also lost both his parents
owen coffin and charles ramsdell had
each lost a father
this may have been their closest bond
each of them like so many nantucketers
was a fatherless child for whom a ship's
officers would be much more than a
demanding taskmaster he would be quite
possibly the first male authority figure
the boys had ever known
now on nantucket
we have a attend i think any community
where the history of the place
is integral to the economy of the place
there's a tendency to romanticize that
past
and whaling has inevitably been a part
of that tendency on nantucket and i know
it really wasn't until i began
thoroughly researching this book that i
came to understand what was involved
in whaling what was involved in killing
the whale and transforming it into
blubber and i'd like to read you a a
brief passage describing the process
because
i think there is a tendency to think
that the harpoon was thrown
and uh it hit the whale then poof uh the
whale became uh casks of whale oil but
it was a little a little more
complicated than that
this is uh the this is describes the
first whale the the men killed
they had a few days before they had
sighted whales but uh one of the whales
had bashed
the first mate's boat thrown at sky high
throwing the men into the water and
putting a hole into the boat so they had
to abandon the hunt and
return to the ship for repairs so once
again two days later they sight whales
several days after chase's boat was
repaired the lookout once again cited
whales
the boats were dispatched a harpoon was
hurled successfully and the whale line
went whizzing out until it was finally
snubbed at the loggerhead a post in the
aft portion of the whale boat
launching the boat and crew on the
voyage's first nantucket sleigh ride as
it would come to be called
merchant seaman spoke derisively about
the slow speeds of the average bluff
bowed whale ship but the truth of the
matter was that no other sailors in the
early 19th century experienced the
speeds of nantucket whalemen
and instead of doing it in the safe
confines of a large three-masted ship
the nantucketer traveled in a 25-foot
boat crammed with half a dozen men rope
and freshly sharpened harpoons and
lances
the boat rocked from side to side and
bounced up and down as the whale dragged
it along at speeds that would have left
the fleetest naval frigate wallowing in
its wake
when it came to sheer velocity over the
water a nantucketer pinned to the flank
of a whale that was pulling in miles and
miles from a whale ship that was already
hundreds of miles from land was the
fastest seaman in the world traveling at
15 some claimed as many as 20 bone
jarring knots
the harpoon did not kill the whale it
was simply the means by which a whale
boat crew attached itself to its prey
after letting the creature tire itself
out by sounding to great depths or
simply tearing along the water's surface
the men began to haul themselves inch by
inch to within stabbing distance of the
whale
by this point the boats deer and mate
had traded places a miraculous feat in
its own right on a craft as small and
tender as a whale boat not only did
these two men have to contend with the
violent slapping of the boat through the
waves which could be so severe that
nails started from the planks in the bow
and stern but they had to stay clear of
the whale line quivering like a piano
wire down the center line of the boat
eventually however the boat's deer made
it aft to the steering oar and the mate
who was always given the honor of the
kill took up his position in the bow
if the whale was proving too spirited
the mate would hobble it by taking up a
boat spade and hacking away at the
tendons in the tail
then he'd take up the 11 to 12 foot
killing lance it's petal shaped blade
designed for piercing a whale's vital
organs
but finding the life of a giant swimming
mammal encased in a thick layer of
blubber was not easy
sometimes the mate would be forced to
stab it as many as 15 times probing for
a group of coiled arteries in the
vicinity of the lungs with a violent
churning motion that soon surrounded the
whale boat in a rushing river of bright
red blood
when the lance firmly finally found its
mark the whale would begin to choke on
its own blood its spout transformed into
15 to 20 foot geyser of gore that
prompted the mate to shout chimneys a
fire
as the blood rained down on them the men
took up the oars and backed furiously
away then paused to watch as the whale
went into what was known as its flurry
beating the water with its tail snapping
at the air with its jaws even as it
regurgitated large chunks of fish and
squid the creature began to swim in an
ever-tightening circle
then just as abruptly as the attack had
begun with the first thrust of the
harpoon it ended the whale fell
motionless and silent a giant black
corpse floating fin up in a slick of its
own blood and vomit
this may have been the first time thomas
nickerson that 14 year old boy had ever
helped kill a warm blooded animal
back on nantucket where the largest wild
quadruped was the norway rat was not
quite a wilderness out there
there were no deer or even rabbits to
hunt
and as any hunter knows killing takes
some getting used to
even though this brutal and bloody
display was the supposed dream of every
young man from nantucket the sentiments
of an 18 year old green hand enoch cloud
who kept a journal during his voyage on
a whale ship are telling
it is painful to witness the death of
the smallest of god's created things
much more one in which life is so
vigorously maintained as the whale
and when i saw this the largest and most
terrible of all created animals bleeding
quivering dying a victim to the cunning
of man
my feelings were indeed peculiar
well finally i'd like to
take you back to nantucket
nantucket today because in the epilogue
i relate what was truly a miraculous
event on nantucket
a couple of new years ago
the dead of winter a sperm whale
appeared off the east end of the island
in wisconsin it's 46 feet long half the
length of the whale that attacked the
essex it was sick
and
eventually died and washed up on the
beach
and
the fisheries department
granted nantucket the right to keep the
skeleton and so the skeleton of this
sperm whale of course the creature to
which the island was devoted and
pursuing for hundreds of years
this this
skeleton will soon become the
centerpiece of a new museum complex uh
whaling museum complex on nantucket
uh the the uh and the antichrist got a
real firsthand
uh look at what was involved in whaling
uh the the whale died they had to hack
all the blubber and guts off the
skeleton dumping them a hole in the sand
they even
were allowed to use some of the
implements back at the whaling museum
which were sharpened up after 100 years
of of uh being on display and uh proved
once again how good these nantucketers
were in terms of the technology they
applied to their craft
and then these bones after spending the
winter uh in a hole in the ground
were were brought disinterred
placed in cages and put in uh
the harbored water for the entire summer
they they came up uh that fall and
except for a few barnacles they were
clean
these these uh tremendous bones are now
in a shed at the historical association
they're still oozing oil
and when this new uh
complex is put together they will become
the basis of really the centerpiece
of of this museum and in the book in the
epilogue i talk about not only this but
what remains on nantucket uh
of the essex
there is the historical association has
just opened a wonderful exhibit
based on about the essex disaster and if
you make it out to nantucket i really
encourage you to see this exhibit
and um there are there are a few few
artifacts there are some of the houses
of the um
some of the survivors to be seen and i
talk about this and then this is how i
end the book
but it is the newly acquired skeleton of
the sperm whale oozing oil from the
nantucket historical association shed
that speaks most powerfully to the
tragedy of the whale ship essex
the nourishing life-saving bones of
their dead comrades were what pollard
and ramsdell clung to so fiercely even
after their ordeal had ended
and it is bones that nantucketers cling
to now
tangible reminders of a time when the
island was devoted to the business of
transforming whales into money
in moby dick ishmael tells of seeing the
skeleton of a sperm whale assembled in a
grove of palm trees on a south pacific
island
how vain and foolish he says for timid
untraveled man to try to comprehend a
right this wondrous whale by merely
pouring over his dead attenuated
skeleton
only in the heart of quickest perils
only when within the endings of his
angry flukes
only on the profound unbounded sea
can the fully invested whale be truly
and livingly found out
but as the survivors of the essex came
to know once the end has been reached
and all hope
passion and force of will have been
expended the bones may be all that are
left
thank you
[Applause]
well thank you i think we have some time
for some questions if uh any of you
would
uh have questions about it yes was it
clear at the time that
the
african-americans were among those
other than joyce
that died first was that part of the
story that came back or just that
virtually everybody yeah the question
the question is is
the fact the african-americans the four
of the first men to die and be eaten
would be african-americans which given
the demographics of the ship is
certainly an unsettling uh statistic
and
in chase's account
and this occurred
among pollards and the second mates vote
and chase's account of course is
primarily talking about his own boat
which had been divided from the others
and what he does is uh provide a summary
of what happened on on those other boats
at the end so that he if you looked at
who who died and matched up with you
know who they were you could figure out
uh this this this demographics of death
but the uh fact of the matter is it was
nothing that was uh uh pointed out
for anyone and this was one of the
things i wanted to tackle with this book
is to expl try to explore why uh this
happened there's no evidence of any kind
of favoritism when it came to the
distribution of racials among the men
but the fact of the matter was that the
african-americans
nickerson tells us we're all uh housed
in the foxhole of the ship up forward
and at this era in wailing on nantucket
it was very typical for the men up
forward to to be fed less and and
food of poorer quality
than those who were housed aft as you
make word you made your way aft on the
ship
and uh you're so that your uh your
chances of survival and a ordeal of
starvation depend directly on your
health and nutrition prior to that
ordeal so the african-americans were at
a disadvantage from the beginning but
written another factor was your in which
whale boat you were assigned and four of
the six blacks were assigned to matthew
joy's boat matthew joy the second mate
was suffering from some kind of illness
even before the ordeal it may have been
tuberculosis and he would actually be
the first person to die
what chase tells us it wasn't just
starvation he was sick
but the fact the matter remains if uh
your survival in a or ordeal of any sort
depends a large part on strong
leadership and the men in joy's boat did
not have that because their leader was
dying and so uh these four men when you
look at the nutrition prior to the
ordeal and then the boat placement you
begin to see
there is at least some logic
in
who was dying and when
any other questions
yes
there was a hammering in the boat and
they thought that
uh the whale was trying to answer that
in other words we know now that whales
do communicate right
yeah i'm wondering well one of the one
of the the question is you know what was
involved with this whale attack why did
the whale attack and that that was one
of the
the the
uh problems i wanted to attempt to solve
was to figure out what was going through
this sperm whale's head
owen chase who was first made on the
deck of the ship when it attacked felt
like as if the whale was
it felt to him as if the whale was
attacking them in vengeance for uh what
the other men were doing uh to the the
pot of whales to lure to them uh but in
talking with sperm whale experts i
discovered that male sperm whales and
this was a male sperm whale which are
larger than females don't make any
permanent connections with pods of
whales which are females and juveniles
they once a male reaches a certain age
they swim off go to the high latitudes
stay in either groups of of males or or
stay singly and then return
to mate occasionally and but move from
pod to pod they do however when they run
into another male sperm whale attack
much the way elephants do
and whales communicate with a series of
clicks uh which scientists refer to as
coda's sort of morse code-like series of
clicking noises and uh the whalers could
hear these noises through the timbers of
their ships uh they sounded so much like
the hammering
of a nail that they called them the
carpenter fish
and as it so happens when that whale
appeared to the port of the essex owen
chase was repairing a whale boat
nailing a piece of canvas to the side of
of his damaged whale boat and so the
possibility exists that he was sending
down signals that
at least may have attracted this whale
uh and uh to the to the ship itself a
certainly a cruel irony if indeed chase
was the one that that brought the whale
on him yes
documented cases of whales attacking the
ships
yeah the question is are there other
cases documented cases of whales
attacking ship
a whale ship well prior to this no um it
doesn't mean it never existed there
there were plenty of whale ships that
never returned and no one knew what
happened however up until this time no
but in the decades to come there would
be other instances in which whales would
attack ships and one of the most
interesting ones occurred
in the middle of the 19th century
almost exactly at the same time as
melville's publication of moby dick
a whale would attack the anne alexander
out of new bedford
sink it the men would take to their
whale boats would be rescued but when
melville heard of the attack of this
whale on the ann alexander he would
write to a literary friend my god has my
evil art raised this monster
so there seems to have been a change in
behavior as the there would be other
instances in which whales would attack
ships and the whalemen in general
commented on the change in the behavior
of whales that they they described them
as getting increasingly scary uh they
would even change the design of whale
boats which were in the era of the essex
were or last rake uh uh lapped
construction sort of like the clapboards
of a house and these were if you've ever
been on a laps drake boat they're noisy
when they move through the water
and uh the whales
the whalemen felt that they were
spooking the whales so that they went to
a smooth sided construction carvel
and uh these boats were quieter and so
that you can see that they uh clearly
there was something going on uh in in
the minds of these whales as the century
progressed
yes
somewhere in a museum the original
um it's there it yeah the it's called
the paddock letter which is which is
pollard's account uh it's there is a
xerox copy of it at the nantucket
historical association no one knows
where the original of that is however
recently
a a letter came to light
which
is written on nantucket just a few days
after the return of owen chase to the
island
which describes
chase's condition uh that
he's even though this is months after
his ordeal he can he's choked his tears
come when he tries to talk about it and
can't continue but then includes um
a copy of the paddock letter uh that so
it's clear that this letter was widely
circulated and it's amazing document and
it's clear that owen chase when he wrote
his account that summer with the help of
a ghost writer depended on that letter
because uh the the information that's in
there makes its way into his account
yes um how would it take you to do all
the research on the um book yeah the
question is how long did it take me to
do all the research on this book it took
me a very long time
it's really hard to say because i began
writing and researching
books about nantucket more than 10 years
ago
and in my first book about nantucket
away offshore the essex disaster is a
chapter in that so my research goes back
at least 10 years but working on this
book book it was three years of of work
and so it took a long time
well thank you very much
[Applause]
nathaniel philbrook is the director